la alianza de ultraderecha liderada por
Georgia melón y se impone con
contundencia las elecciones legislativas
de este domingo en Italia según los
sondeos a pie de urna la Ultra
derechista se convertiría en la primera
mujer en llegar al cargo de primera
ministra en la historia del país tenemos
análisis
el presidente de Ucrania anunció
resultados positivos en la
contraofensiva contra las tropas and
rusas por lo de Mercedes que asegura que
su ejército lucha en regiones clave
mientras algunos ciudadanos se ven
forzados a abandonar las cuatro zonas
que Rusia Busca anexionarse con una
serie de referéndums tenemos al reporte
de nuestro equipo sobre el terreno
una devastación inmensa así definen las
autoridades de Canadá el impacto de la
tormenta Fiona en la costa este del país
que deja al menos un muerto se estima
que se tarde meses en Reparar los daños
de este fenómeno atmosférico sobre
infraestructura clave de la zona
afectada
tiempo de actualizar las noticias en la
pantalla de France 24 Gracias por
continuar con nuestra señal Mi nombre es
Juan pupiales empezamos en Italia en
donde la ultraderechista Georgia melón
iba de Camino hacia la nueva primera
ministra del país algo inédito para una
mujer después de que su Alianza se
impusieran las elecciones legislativas
celebradas este domingo es lo que
auguran los sondeos a pie de urna que le
dan al bloque de meloni entre el 41 y el
45% de los votos algo que le permitiría
controlar las dos salas del parlamento
de confirmarse la Victoria sería también
el regreso de la extrema derecha al
poder por primera vez desde el fin de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial melón y lidera
una alianza que comparte con el ex
Primer Ministro Silvio berlusconi y
Mateo salvine antiguo ministro del
interior el partido democrático de la
principal agrupación de Centro izquierda
reconoció ya su derrota en los comicios
y habló de una noche triste para el país
para analizar este tema conectamos con
el periodista gui quien nos atiende
desde ancona en Italia Señor casoly
gracias por estar con nosotros como
explicar este fuerte regreso de la
extrema derecha Italia
Hola
buen día Bueno acá son las 12 de la
mañana en primer lugar
[Música]
cómo explicar eso es algo que en Italia
se sabía desde hace por lo menos cuatro
o cinco meses porque porque en primer
lugar Italia está acusando la peor
crisis económica y social desde el
posguerra y secundariamente hay que
decir que el el partido democrático
en vez de pensar en Cómo solucionar los
problemas
de la gente recordamos que nos Está
golpeada solamente a la clase más baja
sino también muchísima muchísima familia
de la clase media no pueden llegar con
su sueldo a fin de mes con sueldos que
hasta cuatro cinco seis meses atrás
podrían vivir bastante tranquilo
entonces
por esa por esa razón
la la supuesta leyemos así a izquierda
que se ha transformado en algo Bastante
no ha tomado en serio los problemas de
la gente miente Un idioma de este grado
ha hablado a la derecha Ahora hay otro
dato para poner en claro porque es algo
que ha tenido un eco a nivel mundial
Y qué ha sido el eslogan principal
totalmente equivocado del partido
democrático O sea que acreditado a la
vuelta del fascismo en Italia bueno Eso
no es verdad porque la la coalición de
su trineo era una colisión de Centro
derecha eso está el itálica es un
partido conservador adentro Italia hay
personas que han sido
práctico del fascismo como adentro del
partido democrático
tiene personas que han sido fanáticas
del comunismo Y entonces esto no quiere
absolutamente decir que
este esta coalición de centros de
derecho hacia una exposición extrenista
estamos en una democracia la democracia
permite la cermantes
de los poderes alternados por poderes Ok
y estamos en esa etapa Lamentablemente
más de 10 años de gobierno de partidos
entre el partido democrático el
movimiento populista chico
anda decidimos así perdido esta
gravísima situación que no es
absolutamente hija de los últimos cuatro
o cinco meses es una situación que en
Italia está Desde hace dos años y vuelvo
a repetirlo en la peor crisis a nivel
social
que Italia sea con la cual Italia se
está enfrentando desde el fin de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial
señor gasóleo y todo apuntada como
venimos contando que yo ya melón iba a
ser entonces la nueva primera ministra
de Italia Cómo ha sido la trayectoria
política de ella
política que
empezó en el movimiento social
movimientos sociales era el partido
fascista que empezó en el 1947 entrando
entrando prácticamente en el parlamento
italiano y luego cuando
en los años 90 se quebró especialmente
después de manipulit y la derechas se
desarrolló y
se puso con ella se puso en falsa Italia
el movimiento partido ha hecho
robelusconi que ganó las elecciones de
1994 entonces
Italia para luego pagar luego salir de
este partido y hacer el suyo que es
fertilidad que a la última elecciones ha
tenido el 15% en esta elección
exploradora lo dan al
25.6%. Entonces ese es un es un
resultado de una alternativa de poder
que esperamos todos
que pueda solucionar la crisis que es
gravísima o sea cualquier poder que iba
con a ganar que iba a ganar Esa es la
elecciones se encontraba con una bomba
atómica en la mano que es esta crisis
que si no se va a solucionar la provocar
esta situación social ella a partir del
mes de octubre señor guido gasóleo
Muchísimas gracias por su tiempo y su
análisis aquí en francés 24 cambiamos de
tema el presidente de Ucrania habló de
resultados positivos en la
contraofensiva de su ejército contra las
tropas del kremlin en las últimas
semanas quien ha conseguido importantes
avances en este conflicto llevando a que
esta semana el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin movilizara parcialmente a sus
reservistas escuchamos a selenski
se están produciendo intensos combates
en muchas áreas de primera línea que se
extienden en un total de más de 2.000
kilómetros Esta es la región de donisca
esta es la región de gerson y también
las regiones de nikolaive Y saporiya
tenemos resultados positivos en varias
direcciones Y pase lo que pase esta
semana en Rusia sean cuales sean los
pasos que esté planteando el gobierno
terrorista en lo político o militar la
tarea de nuestro estado la tarea de
Ucrania no puede cambiar estamos
luchando por la vida y la libertad de
todos los ucranianos
precisamente son en algunas zonas en las
que en algunas zonas en las que Ucrania
Avanza en esa contra ofensiva en las que
Rusia Está celebrando una serie de
referéndums con Los que buscan
accionarse esas localidades está
empujado a muchos ucranianos que viven
en la zonas ocupadas a abandonar sus
hogares un equipo de Francia 24 informa
desde un punto de paso entre el
territorio ocupado por Rusia y el
controlado por Ucrania veamos
la frontera de la ocupación rusa se
encuentra Más allá de esta carretera
estas personas están de nuevo enteras
controladas por Ucrania a tres
kilómetros del frente tienen la
impresión de que por poco han escapado
de una trampa
pensamos que podríamos quedarnos hasta
final de mes pero en vista de la
situación nos fuimos enseguida
huyen de una movilización parcial
declarada por el kremlin esta medida
solo debería afectar a los hombres rusos
pero en los territorios ocupados se
celebra un referéndum sobre la anexión
rusa estos hombres hablan de urnas
llevadas de casa en casa y de un voto
organizado con poca libertad de elección
bien acompañados de al menos dos
soldados y a veces junto a un vehículo
con una ametralladora
cuando ves como organizan el referéndum
cuando van de casa en casa armados eso
te da una idea de cómo nos reclutarán
rodearán el pueblo traerán el autobús y
listo habremos desaparecido yo prefiero
morir por mi país que morir allí a
voluntad de Putin
estas personas pudieron abandonar los
territorios ocupados sin dificultad pero
para muchos jóvenes Ya es demasiado
tarde
en el último punto de control allí donde
los residentes pasan ya no dejan salir a
los hombres de 18 a 35 años los bloquean
el número de personas que llegan aquí a
disminuido En comparación con lo normal
por lo que sabemos que ha aumentado el
número de personas que quieren salir
algunos están reunidos con sus seres
queridos tras una larga separación a
otros no los verán durante un tiempo
dejados atrás Al otro lado del frente
las autoridades de al menos cinco
provincias canadienses evaluaron hoy los
daños causados por la ahora tormenta
tropical Fiona que tocó tierra en el
este del país este sábado a su paso el
fenómeno atmosférico dejó un rastro de
destrucción sin precedentes y se
necesitarán meses para la recuperación
hasta el momento se reporta al menos una
víctima mortal Rafael Pérez nos cuenta
más
a su paso por la costa del este del país
la hora tormenta tropical Fiona dejó un
rastro de destrucción en al menos cinco
provincias una de las ciudades más
afectadas fue post donde más de 20 casas
quedaron en ruinas entre una población
de 4000 personas
en ese momento les diré que solo estamos
en una pequeña parte de la comunidad
pero el nivel de magnitud de esta
tormenta es muy grande más grande de lo
que pensábamos
en otra ciudad los árboles caídos las
casas destruidas y largas Colas en las
gasolineras imperan en el panorama de
este territorio de Nueva Escocia en esta
región igual que en Isla del príncipe
Eduardo Terranova Quebec y nuevo
brandswake cientos de miles de
residentes permanecieron sin
electricidad las predicciones eran de
una tormenta masiva una tormenta
histórica ciertamente hemos visto eso
Fiona definitivamente dejó una huella en
la provincia el daño es bastante
desgarrador yo no fue la tormenta de más
fuerza en tocar suelo canadiense tras su
paso las labores de recuperación
iniciaron con el envío de las fuerzas
armadas para ayudar en la remoción de
escombros el Primer Ministro Justin
trudó convocó una reunión con el grupo
de respuestas de emergencia para
coordinar el accionar del gobierno en
las labores de reconstrucción
Brasil se prepara para la primera vuelta
de sus elecciones presidenciales del
próximo fin de semana en las que el
actual mandatario Yair bolsonaro Busca
seguir en el cargo el favorito de las
encuestas y el izquierdista Luis y nació
violada Silva ha vuelto y a la campaña
Un día después de haberse ausentado en
el segundo debate presidencial que
reunía a sus rivales más detalles en el
siguiente informe
fue un mito infectivo el de este domingo
dato presidencial Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva se dirigió a una multitud de
seguidores en una escuela de samba de
Río de Janeiro apuntó a su principal
rival el actual presidente Yair bolso y
también abordó su decisión de no
participar en el debate presidencial a
principios del fin de semana
me gusta el debate pero se está
volviendo difícil porque pocas personas
están en condiciones de presentarse a
las elecciones y los otros cinco
candidatos que asistieron al debate solo
tenían un objetivo atacarme porque estoy
en primer lugar
[Música]
un sondeo reciente situado a Lula en
cabeza con el 47% de la intención de
Voto seguido por bolsonaro con el 33 el
ultraderechista le restó importancia a
las cifras
no me fío de las encuestas en 2018
datafolia no acertó nada absolutamente
nada no sé dónde están sus votantes
porque acabo de ir la semana pasada a
granos fui recibido como una estrella
del pop con profundo respeto de la gente
el candidato de Centro izquierda Gómez
dijo que la ausencia de Lula demostraba
que era demasiado confiado
de ser elegido sería su tercer mandato
como presidente procedente de la clase
Obrera se formó como metalúrgico y se
involucró en el activismo sindical fundó
junto a otros el partido de los
trabajadores en 1980 su legado es mixto
se le atribuyen importantes y reformas
como el aumento del salario mínimo pero
su imagen se vio empañada por una
Estancia en prisión condenas por soborno
que luego fueron desestimadas sin
ninguno de los candidatos obtiene la
mayoría de los votos se enfrentarán en
una segunda vuelta el 30 de octubre
terminamos con información del mundo del
espectáculo porque la cantante Rihanna
estará al frente del show de medio
tiempo en la próxima edición del Super
Bowl que se va a disputar en Arizona el
próximo 12 de febrero la artista de
Barbados había cancelado su actuación en
2019 en apoyo al jugador quien hizo
popular la protesta de la rodilla contra
los abusos policiales ahora desde la
organización la definen como un talento
generacional
[Música]
con música despedimos esta emisión
informativa en la pantalla de frases 24
ustedes quédense en nuestra señal y
también visiten nuestro sitio web France
24.com
[Música]